Okay.
Let's now talk about polling.
Donald Trump continues to collapse in the
polls, and this should really scare us.
It should really scare you.
The people who want to remove Trump are the
ones who should be most scared by Donald Trump's
polling collapse.
And this I've decided I can't not cover the
polls because the polls are remarkable in
terms of how they compare to polls in past
elections.
So I can't not talk about the polls, but the
framing has to be.
The polls should scare us because they might
keep people home.
The anti Trump voter may become complacent
if they see too many of these polls that show
Joe Biden winning.
So the polls are looking good for Joe Biden,
and that should scare us because we don't
want anybody to stay home as a result.
The only possible result of Joe Biden polling
well, if we don't take this approach is that
some people who don't like Trump will say,
I don't really need to vote.
I'm just going to stay home because you don't
need my vote.
Biden is going to win.
That's exactly what we need to dissuade people
from doing, so let's take a look at the latest
national polls and then some of the important
state numbers.
So nationally, Joe Biden is leading Donald
Trump by an average of eight point seven.
That's a big lead.
The polls ranged from Leeds as small as four
and as large as 14 for Joe Biden with an average
of eight point seven.
These are crazy numbers.
This is a much bigger lead than Hillary Clinton
had.
And that's why this is scary to me, because
this can change.
These could be off by the full margin of error.
These polls could make people think, I don't
need to vote.
We'll get back to that.
Looking at the important battleground states,
we see that Arizona has Biden up three and
a half.
Florida has Biden up five.
In Michigan, Biden is up seven and a half
in North Carolina.
Biden is up by three in New Hampshire.
Biden's up by four and a half.
There is a tie in Ohio, a state that Donald
Trump won 2016 in Pennsylvania and Wisconsin.
Joe Biden is polling about six and a half
points ahead.
These are obviously very good numbers for
Joe Biden.
If you start with the 2016 map and then flip
to Biden, the states where he is now winning
in the polls, Joe Biden wins easily with more
than 330 electoral votes.
And that's why we should be scared.
We cannot afford to have a single person stay
home because they think Biden has your state
in the bag.
I'll give you an example.
And this is an extreme example.
I vote in Massachusetts.
Biden is currently winning in Massachusetts
by 31 points.
Trump is not going to win in Massachusetts.
But you'd be a you had better be damn sure
that I am going to vote.
Massachusetts earlier this week, I told you,
has confirmed vote by mail is available to
everybody and they will be sending out absentee
ballot applications to every registered voter.
So that's my view.
In Massachusetts, where Biden is winning by
31, if you are in any state, I don't care
what state you're in.
You should imagine your vote.
Visualize your vote flipping the election
from Trump to Biden.
Imagine that that is the importance of your
vote.
If you knew, you could be the difference maker
between your state going to Trump and Biden.
I hope I hope that you would go out and vote.
If you want to have a say, that's exactly
how you have a say.
So we're going to report on polling.
I'm not going to ignore the polling story
because it is an interesting story.
You know, an incumbent president with this
low of an approval rating just four months
out, that is news.
And I'm not going to it would be weird for
me to do a daily show about mostly about American
politics and not talk about that.
But the way I'm going to couch it is we should
be scared by these numbers because the last
thing we want is horrible, gut wrenching disappointment.
Again, on November 3rd or November 4th or
November 10th, however long it takes to count
all of those votes, that will be coming in
by mail.
We're going to continue covering the polling
and asking for your thoughts on the David
Pakman show, Instagram page, which is simply
David Pakman show all one word on Instagram.
Also, if you want to see video, people are
loving this.
Some people went completely crazy.
Rioting in the streets when I posted this
video on my personal Instagram.
There is a video of me harvesting my two spicy
peppers.
These things are so crunchy.
You will not believe it.
OK.
Follow me on Instagram.
Atavist got Pacman.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.